thank you David I was worried that the
introduction will go on and then you
know how have you been more embarrassed
so I want to thank you for asking me to
present this talk and also want to thank
Alastair and everyone else here at the
Simon's Institute for organizing this
program for being so patient with David
and Jake Kumar and myself thank you very
much and and of course I want to thank
mr. Simons for his generosity that made
all of this possible so and I think
maybe the one complaint that I have is
that you know we're here for a boot camp
which you know something like this I
don't think it would like to go in and
suffer and so on so I think if we have
everyone here it's probably because they
didn't really think they're coming to a
boot camp for you so for example my
students they didn't think they don't
think they came for boot camp they think
they came for vacation and and and and
as far as I'm concerned I think we're
here for
not for boot camp but just like for a
walk in the park so I would like to make
this presentation very leisurely and
very calm and and and and look for like
low-hanging fruit and something that
everyone will can relax and understand
and hopefully be happy and and and this
by the way is on one of my favorite
pictures I will see if a couple more
later on and mr. Simons I know you're
taping this this this talk and I know
you're watching it so if you have a
little bit left maybe you can help me
get the original
and and the reason I'm showing this on
on Chrome rather than on my PDF is
because of a bunch of things that happen
the last few days that I think few
people here know about so you know like
organizing the ITA workshop and so the
lots of emails going on and then it
thinkin's two days ago whatever that was
I figured okay it's time to stop and
start working on this on the slides but
then my computer got backed up with all
these emails and there was no more
memory so I had to remove like a few
gigabytes or something so that took a
few hours and I was doing it they got
nervous and I spilled some water on the
laptop so that's why now I have this is
my keyboard now so that took like going
to the Apple store or waiting for three
hours than doing something and this was
the end solution and then flew here
yesterday and there was something we
know there was like weather issues that
it's in San Francisco so the flight got
delayed two hours and then they said
okay fine
you know the week' we can go but as we
get on a plane they realize there's a
mechanical problem so I delayed another
hour and a half and so on and by the
time I got you this there is rush hour
in the in the afternoon so with a few
hours delay there and then this morning
I saw I'm working on the slides with
peuta we go to cafes Strada
to meet and I took a cab and as I get
there I say hmm I lost my cell phone in
a car luckily the car driver gave me his
card so um so I called it the driver no
answer I called my phone once so try
like five times no answer
finally the same car driver just stops
in front and stops in front so I said
well maybe he got I left a message I
should say so so I said great you came I
said I left the phone so he said
interesting because the people that I
took after you they told me something
about the phone but I didn't understand
what they said
so okay so what did you take them he
took them to the Clermont Hotel so can
we go to the Clermont hotel so we went
to the so he said the other checked in
and and declare hotel so we go to the
clientele said there are a couple of
people were checked in here can we can
we look for them they said no nobody
checked in the last hour you know so so
sudden maybe there because they didn't
see them really checking he was just
assuming this checking so they said look
at the restaurant maybe they went to the
restaurant okay so I don't know how the
looks are going to get the card driver
it comes in looks them found one couple
he says them okay so we good did you did
you um did you on drive with this guy
and and they said no no no we've been
here for a long time so luckily he has
his cell phone I said let's give it one
more try
let's call him my number one more time
so I call this no honor so I call this
number and sure enough the ring someone
picked up the phone so I said oh I try
calling you so many times I said no no
we didn't know how to open it so so you
know like you need to on you need to
open you know like when the someone
calls in to slide it and they didn't
know how to slide until that time so
okay in case they give me a phone it
drove me back and then when I was
driving back when driving back I said oh
I'm so glad that you you heard my my
phone message and you came to you know
to confess Rhonda says no I didn't hear
your phone message so said so how did
you come to the cafe he said I always go
there to have coffee on my breath so so
anyway so worked up so okay so now you
see there the meaning of leisurely
stroll in the park and we can
just click on this line I can opt-in
Acrobat maybe but okay so so this talk
is about estimating probabilities with
application and application and it's
done with mainly with my student and
Toyota who is okay oh there is okay
and his worked a lot on this and but
also there are many contributions by
many of my former students and postdocs
at ITA who have done a lot of work on
many different things some of them I'll
talk about some of them I won't and
other people as well so start so what we
want to talk about is learning from data
and and that is understanding and
utilizing observations that we have I
should mention that because of all these
delays not all the slides will be up to
the same level of sophistication so and
so what are the problems that we want to
do we want to learn the underlying
distribution we want to learn
distribution properties of the
distributions for example the support
size and the entropy and we want to look
at applications of publications include
compression prediction and so we want we
have data we want to compress it we see
some data we want to predict the nessa
next element and identity testing means
that you you are someone gives you some
distribution to say is the data that you
observed coming from that distribution
closeness testing someone gives true
distribution to two streams of data and
ask you do they come from the same
distribution of from two different
distributions and classification someone
gives you like good emails and bad
emails and the new unit comes in and you
want to classify it into good or bad
okay and because of that they have a
broad relevance people have looked at
them in different disciplines many
different disciplines particular in
statistics people have looked at those
power
for many many years I mean formation
theory and in computer science so so
maybe one advantage of this is you write
one paper and you can publish it in
three different places well small
variations that's different application
so ok so let me very quickly go over
this so over this one of the slides that
I need to improve so what we'll do is I
will try to look the approaches that
will take as well try to get results
that work always so therefore any
distribution they're going to work well
and and we so and we try to be close to
optimal to the best that you can do so
and select for example in Turk when you
have compression you want to get close
to entropy and you when you estimate
distribution you want to get to almost
the exact distribution that you have and
so of course these are things that
people look at for a long time and I
think what has been different in the
last 10 15 years is the people have
started looking at domains that are
large not just flipping coins or
something but large domains and then
there are new problems that come in and
that's that's what how we're going to do
so and so so what we'll do is today
we're going to discuss basically
compression so I'm sorry public
estimation we're going to look at
estimating a collection of distributions
and see how well we can do next
on Thursday what we'll do is look at
relaxing the requirements because we'll
see that some things are difficult to do
so look at the relaxing the requirements
too so that we can achieve things and on
Friday we look at some applications like
property testing and and classification
and so on
so so let's start with as we said with
probability estimation so this is of
course one of the oldest problems in
existence so you have a coin with
probability P heads and P tails
and there's some two one
and you want to have estimate the
probability of heads so what you do is
you flip the coin n times R
independently and
Oh
so okay so you want to estimate the
public effects what you do is you flip
flip the coin ten times and let n H be
the number of times they've seen a heads
and you're in pretty frequent I'm pickle
frequency estimator F R stands for
frequency is the number of times we've
seen head heads divided divided by n so
for example if you see heads heads tails
heads tails then what probability would
you assign to heads while you flip the
coin five times you've seen three heads
so it's going to be 3/5 and why does
this estimator work because by the law
of large numbers F H this this fraction
will converge to what will converge to
its right value P H okay and so it's so
the expected value of F off and that's
because the expectation of F H is always
pH okay and and the standard deviation
is what is the square root of n times P
H times PT and I knew normalize it by n
so it goes down like 1 over square root
of N and that most 1 over 2 square root
of n okay so we have an estimator whose
expected value is always the right value
the standard deviation cone goes down to
zero like 1 over 2 square root of n at
most so it don't for converges to and
because of this you can show that the
absolute value of FH the estimate minus
pH is at most it's always at most a
standard deviation and so it's at most 1
over 2 square root of N and so so if
you're trying to estimate the
distribution P H and P tail to l1
distance then you get that it's at most
if it's most twice this this value
because each one you estimate to it in
expectation you distances at most 1 over
2 square root of N and this result is
for expectation but if you wanted to get
results that all with high probability
then very similar results will hold if
you want the results to probability
to hold probability 1 minus Epsilon then
you'll be off by the most another term
of log of 1 1 over epsilon so these
results they this result what we wrote
here is the expectation but if you said
it the result will get will hold with
very high probability then essentially
the same result well so but this is for
alphabet of size 2 and when we flip
coins and and these results are useful
for a couple of things they're useful
for homework problems and are useful for
information theorists anywhere else
is not flipping a coin even in Las Vegas
they're not flipping coins anymore
alphabet is larger ok so if you look at
biology then you might look at our
population estimation trying to estimate
how many how many how many people live
in a certain location how many animals
are in a certain habitat or how many
species are there and so on so then the
number is could be hundreds - mm okay so
you take samples and you wait till you
see the same species or different
species so your alphabet is the number
of species or number of animals it's
fairly large in genetics you might want
to do genetic analysis or mutation
survey and your alphabet size is the
number of genes which is roughly 25,000
you do language processing like speech
recognition or machine translation or
text classification and so on then our
topic modeling is try to see what what
is the topic of the document then your
alphabet is the set of words and in
English it's half a million so so
alphabet size 2 is rarely the case and
that's what people have noticed that you
need to look at larger alphabets and
that's why all these results that we are
talking about and so also in marketing
maybe maybe you are Netflix and you want
to know which movie to recommend to
peoples you alphabet' or maybe your
Amazon and selling some products or some
social network we have people so your
alphabet size is thousands or maybe many
thousands case of movies millions in the
case of Amazon and social networks you
know like could be billions or something
so this is you have like number of
people in the world maybe 6 6 million or
something like okay so so in any case
that everything that deals with big data
often you have something that either
books on a large domain or or in high
dimensions or something like that so
what we want to do is we want to learn
large alphabet known over large domains
so the alphabet instead of two will
become K and I'm asking you to remember
this because I gave you know like a
early version of this talk I some time
ago and the day and someone told me I
would like to talk a lot but there was
the one thing that he didn't remember
and that was what is K so so just make
sure remember the case the ability so so
looking at distributions of a key
element so we let Delta K be the
simplest in the simplex in okay so Delta
2 is that collection X 1 X 2 that are
non-negative and sum to 1 so
distribution is just is just an element
of of this simplex the same
and and we'll be giving an samples and
in the stock we'll assume that
everything is iid so we given n samples
x1 up to xn the distributor going to P
and are independent and will come up
with an estimator e which is a function
of what we have observed x1 up to xn and
it estimates each of those p1 up to pk
so the estimator is a 1 all the way up
to VK and we'll look as we as we have
said we look at the worst-case estimator
estimation error which is so we have
some distance in mind and for every P
we'll observe our a sequence xn of n
samples so there's some distance between
P and our estimate and look at the
expectation of this distance and that's
our error that we make and will maximize
it over all distributions all possible
distributions so this is the distance
that of if for the worst distribution
they expect the distance of e4
distribution and like I said we're doing
it for expectation because it's the
easiest thing to write and explain but
if you want to do things that work with
high probability you can do that as well
so this is the estimate for a specific
estimator II but of course you're going
to choose the best estimator so the dkn
is going to be your loss or your your
miss estimate is going to be the one
that it's achieved by the a that
minimizes this this error so it's the
middle and that's the best distance for
the worst distribution so it's a min/max
result you're looking at take for every
estimator you look at the worst distance
that you will get on average and you
choose the estimator that gives you the
the lowest such distance so it's a
function of the alphabet size and the
number of samples so what people have
looked at you know the probability
estimation has hundreds of years of
history and what people have looked at
mostly is just like they didn't look at
large alphabets it just looked at okay I
have a coin and I want to flip it many
times and then how well is my estimate
going to work what happens when K is
large could be comparable to n and so on
very few results okay so so of course an
important question is what distance were
going to put here
and we're going to look at two relevant
distance mayor
okay one is the l1 distance which comes
in for classification and machine
learning applications we'll see that on
Friday and that is if you have a
distribution P and you have an estimate
either one distance just the summation
of the true values minus your estimate
absolute value okay so that's one
distance and the other is the KL
divergence which comes in compression
and prediction and KL divergence between
the true distribution P and your
estimate e is the summation of P I log
of P I divided by di is that clear any
questions anyone has everyone is okay so
so basically we will interested in two
distinct two distances and in this talk
will again try to be as strong in the
park so we'll talk mostly almost all
almost exclusively about l1 distance one
thing that I maybe want to say before I
move to large alphabet is if we if you
remember for just alphabet of size two
we said that your error in your error is
going to be your l1 distance error was
going to be the most one over square
root of n right it's also a lower one
and it's easy to see that because
suppose so we're looking for an
estimator that will work for all
distributions okay so in this case all
Bernoulli distributions every P but
suppose that I help you out and I tell
you that P is either 1 plus 1 or 1/2
plus 1 over square root of N or 1/2
minus 1 over square root of n so I'm
just going to help you out and tell you
and just look at these two distributions
okay then then the best thing you can do
it's easy to see so I tell you have to
this my disability
Bernoulli 1/2 plus 1 over square root of
N open only 1/2 minus 1 over square root
of n ok and now you take n samples it's
easy to see that the best thing you can
do is if then if you get more than if
you get more ones than 0 you assume it's
it's 1/2 plus 1 over square root of N
and otherwise you get 2 it's 1/2 minus 1
over square n so
just say what is the what is the
probability that you make mistake
alright and so the standard deviation is
going to be roughly 1 over square root
of n correct and so with constant
probability you flip to the other side
so therefore the you cannot hope for
something that gives you more than one
of a squirt of in distance yeah
everything depends a lot on the distance
okay so so to see what happens
for when you go from alphabet of size 2
to alphabet of size K let's first look
at in this case just for a second let's
look at the l2 distance okay instead of
the other one just just because we'll
use it in later on so and let's look and
see what FX which is the empirical
frequency what he does okay so we're
looking at the L the expected value of
the l2 distance so it's summation of X
of P X minus F X okay and this is just
the variance of your estimator for px so
so this the various is going to be x
times 1 minus P X okay and times N and
you normalize divide you divide by n so
it's it's going to divide by n square so
you'll get over n like this and this the
summation P X will sum to 1 okay and
here you have a minus summation of px
square so summation PX minus summation
PX well like that okay and then if you
look at summation px square it's always
bigger than or equal to the case where
they're all equal and we're all equal
then each of them will give you 1 of a
distribution over k elements so each of
them gives you 1 over K Square and you
some care of them so you'll get 1 over K
so so it's always are at most this value
okay because this you'll be subtracting
a number which is bigger than one of the
King so so this is for L this is for l2
now going back to l1 and we won't see
what empirical estimator achieves and
then what you have is we're looking at
we want to evaluate
the expected value of summation of P X
minus F X absolute value so let's first
look at the square so if you look at the
square you can pretend that you have
summation of 1 times this and use Cauchy
Schwartz so what you'll get is it's at
most the expected value of summation of
1 times the expected value of this
quantity square but summation of 1 will
always be K and this expectation is just
the l/2 distance which is at most this
value minus 1 over K over N and so you
multiply them together you get K minus 1
over N so this is the expected value of
l1 square if you look at between st.
expect the value of l1 so it's going to
be the square root of this which is
square root of K minus so what this
shows is that as there are if K was
equal to 2 you got 1 over square root of
n if K is any number then your L u L 1
this distance is square root of K over
so this is this this is a rough result
and in fact you can you can also do it
exactly and so in this talk almost
everything will do will be just up to
constant but if you want to estimate the
constant the exact they namely we'll
just have order of results if you want
to find the exact constant that's a
completely different form it's no longer
a probability estimation form it becomes
a problem of using for Pournami
approximation and so on so it's just you
calculate just the summation of this of
the of the terms and then for KL
divergence there's a lot of work and
finally breast rice and sour in 2004 so
this is just very recent like 10 years
ago the show that for KL divergence the
best you can do is came what K minus 1
over 2 n so I feel look it expected you
you're given n samples and you try to
estimate the distribution to the small
kale divergence our divergence and the
best you can do is K minus 1 over 2 n
and and then Sudeep come off he was a
postdoc and he showed it for l1 the best
that you can do is two x squared we knew
it was roughly K over over N and he
showed the constant which is square root
of two over pi so it's actually
surprising that people have not known
this result before but at least we have
not seen it so ok so I want to relate
next slide that what I want to do is I
want to relate this result to things
that people have done in information
theory so so what this tells us is that
if we want to to approximate the
distribution to within a small to within
a small KL divergence the best we can do
is the alphabetize minus 1 over 2n so
this is related to something people know
so in information theory what you want
to do is is you want so we know that
when you want to compress when you want
to compress the source the best you can
do is get to the entropy of the source
but that's for that you need to use
something like like Huffman coding and
so on you need to know the distribution
if you don't know the distribution then
you need to try and estimate it
effectively and so the what so H of P is
what you can get to if you know the
distribution if you're not don't on the
distribution there'll be some extra loss
if you don't get to H of P you'll get to
some X or loss and this extra lost
people know is K minus 1 times log n
over 2 so so this is a very famous
result in information theory it's called
redundancy so it says that if you are if
you have a distribution over K elements
and you want to compress it without
knowing its entropy what you can do is
you can get to the entropy plus this
term K minus 1 over 2 times log n it's
considered a good result because it goes
sub linearly with with n so as n becomes
larger and larger the entropy will grow
linearly and but the extra term that
you'll pay is just lower with me and and
this is the constant in front and in
fact in information to eat people you
know just not just this but they also
know the constant and
don't know just the constant ignored if
there's another term of one over and
they never calculate all of this exactly
but the issue is that that this term
even though it's very nice you can you
can actually say something which is even
nicer using this result that that that
for KL you get K minus one there you KL
divergence will be K minus 1 over 2n and
the reason is that what you do is you
can the extra loss what you can do is
you can try to come to arm to compress
things one at a time sequentially and at
each each time you're going to lose K
minus 1 over 2n in this n is going to
vary it's going to be K minus 1 over 2
and then K minus 1 over 2 to 2 III is
the number of is the I elements so what
you'll going to get is that your total
redundancies at most summation of K
minus 1 over 2i which is going to give
you K minus 1 over 2 log n so so this
result actually explains this this
universal compression result and I think
it's maybe a little nicer because it
shows you that this log n is just the
harmonic sound matching both of them so
this is this is exact design is plus
plus little off this quantity and this
is also exact and like I said this term
people know this plus the constant that
you have and plus another term which is
like proportional to 1 over n but going
through the estimation that's right no
no correct so this was that's quite so
this will show you that you can get this
you that describe being shown you can
get the upper bound in the first term
why it's not very clear that as the
meaning and then compress okay no no
okay so okay so no no okay so that's it
those are two different slightly
different problems so that's a little
not what they want to talk about but
when you compress one way to view
compression is to do probability
estimation so at any time yours
you make the you estimate you what you
have and then use compression so now we
have it anytime you have a distribution
of you of where are your elements and
then you compress them okay you can do
this second part with with a constant
loss like one or two bits you can use
arithmetic coding so these two problems
are essentially the same so if you if
you try to estimate the distribution as
you go along you can that and then do
the compression is a sort of a central
part so that part is not so interesting
to us because you can decouple those two
parts estimating the distribution and
using it compression but the part that
maybe is a little more interesting is
that this thing is not sequential you
look at the whole sequence and then you
try to compress it as well as you can so
someone gives you a whole sequence of
like the encyclopedia and say compress
it okay it it so happens that that you
can do it you can do that also
sequentially it's really interesting but
maybe not so surprising because you can
see that as time goes by you're going to
learn the distribution right
encyclopedia is size a million then
after half a million you already know
the distribution and for most of the
time you're doing the right compression
so you get the right constant so even
that part it may be not so interested
does that make sense but the constant
you'll find is the same maybe there'll
be like a smaller order terms that would
be different but what I what I wanted to
emphasize is that it shows you where the
log n comes from the log in comes form
is because at every time I you kill
their versions loss is one of rye and
this is just the sum of those so yeah so
so this is what I said if you can
estimate then you can also compress
that's there any questions any other
questions so you you could depending on
the application you could so for example
imagine that I'm going to give you a
string that never ends because I'm going
to for next 10 years I'm going transmit
our temperatures you don't want to wait
10 years and then tell me the
temperature 10 years ago so you won't
transmit them as you go along so that's
one reason if you know you can compress
is in the entropy right but that's so
yeah okay
for its table no no
because okay so okay so first of all I
try to compress the compression part
because I want to talk about a balanced
oh no no no no I'll answer
I'll answer fully as I try to compress
it because I want to concentrate on on
the estimation of the distribution no
but but we'll talk about this but it's
actually a very fascinating topic which
we can see from the from the questions
so so the several different questions
there okay and I think each of them
corresponds to different things that
you've said the easiest one if someone
gives you the distribution someone tells
you here's my distribution okay then you
need the just the entropy on between the
entropy and purpose one that's Huffman
coding okay this beautiful result the
only problem with it is never happens
nobody ever gives you the distribution
so is irrelevant
so then you can say okay I'm looking at
the Encyclopedia Britannica and I'm
going to compress it I have this just
compress it I want to achieve the
entropy okay so I have all the whole
file in front of me and that's what I
want to do okay so then what we can do
is what I think you are saying except I
think you made one small miss
approximation maybe so what I could do
let's assume for simplicity that I'm
looking at sequence of zeros and ones I
could look and say I have so many zeros
and so many ones I have a sequence of
length n okay I can just tell you how
many zeros I have once I tell you how
many zeros I essentially know the
distribution okay and then I transmit it
so to do that I need to travel how many
zeros I need log n bits and then I need
the entropy so this is you do not count
this extra log in bits so so what this
shows what what we have just said shows
that you can get to the entropy plus log
n bits or if the alphabet was size K and
it K minus 1 times log in because I need
to describe the number of times each of
K minus 1 things appeared so what you
can what we have just showed is that the
redundancy the extra number of bits that
we pay for not knowing the distribution
is that most this K minus 1 over 2 and
then the math will show you that it's K
minus 1 over 2 times log n does that
answer your question ok so that's so
that's so this answers the question
about the whole block now the question
comes
in many applications and one might argue
in most application you want to do
things sequentially things come at a
time you don't want to wait for for
eternity and then calculate the the
distribution and and then transmit so
you want to do things as they come along
and it turns out and we can if you want
we can explain that to that when you do
that the redundancy this extra number of
it is the same and I gave you one
intuitive reason that is if you're
looking at sequences that are very large
then you'll get a lot of extra bits you
lose a lot of extra bits at the
beginning but for the last half you will
have learned the distribution like if
the dispersion is binary and you looked
at the billion bits the last half
billion you're doing almost exactly so
as n increases you can see that that you
will not lose by doing it sequentially
ok what you need to do the math and of
course the number will depend on both N
and K and there will be some some more
precise things to be done so is that ok
but what I want to say is that this this
this term of log n using this result are
you can actually explain it
so it comes from the fact that each time
you're off by one over n in your
approximation all right so so this this
I think also mentioned it covers some of
what we have just said so so what I want
to do so so far we talked about up
approximation right and we talked maybe
a little bit about compression so what
we said was that the that your
approximation loss if you alphabet of
size K and you have n samples if you're
looking at l1 distance is quote of K
minus 1 over 2 pi N and so this is very
informative it shows you how fast or how
slow our approximation R decreases to
zero but so will lie it's not that
interesting I don't see people getting
very excited about this ok so so if you
want to get excited about this I think
you beat me to be a little insane and
according to Albert insanity is doing
the same saying the same thing over and
over again and expecting different
results so so what I want to do is a
little insane I want to to say exactly
the same thing and expect a different
level of excitement so so we're going to
instead of looking at the approximation
let's look at the sample complexity so
so so so far we said someone gives you
the number of samples and and we
evaluated the distance that you are from
the distribution what we're going to do
now is reverse the order so we'll say
let's say someone gives you the distance
and you look at the number of samples
we're clearly doing the exact same thing
I don't know even one we're doing it ok
so given Delta distance let s Delta of K
so alphabetic size K it's fixed and
someone gives us some Delta some
distance that they want to be at and
asking what is the smallest number of
samples such that your distance from the
distribution will be at most Delta okay
so maybe I'm trying to learn the
distribution of English words and I want
to approximate it to within n1 distance
of 0.1 asked you how many how many how
many words do I need to look at to as
made its distribution so that we already
have the answer it's I just need to plug
in here Delta and just solve right so
it's the number of samples needed this
estimate all distributions right because
we're looking at the worst one to
distance the Delta and I just plug in
here at Delta and I'll get that that
number of samples so this is Delta I'll
get that n the number of sample is going
to be just K minus 1 over 2 pi Delta
square right so Delta square everything
move on to the other side so this is
exactly we're doing exactly the same
thing right so it's exactly the same
right and so that we get excited maybe
not but let's look at language modeling
which is what you do if you want to if
you need to do any kind of like speech
to text you need to estimate
distribution of words this is actually
done if we do any machine translation if
you all kinds of thing you need to
estimate our distribution of words
so as we said the alphabet size in this
case is half a million that's English
let's say we want to learn to within
distance of one percent point on one
okay then just plug in half a million
divided by two pi Delta Square this is
Delta and you get that you need 800
million words so if you want to estimate
English to 18 point or 1 what you need
is almost a billion words okay so are
you excited maybe not because they say
Oh Google has many billions of for it
right so maybe still not excited so so
then let's note that actually what you
need to do is you don't need to you'll
be you'll be really doing a bad job if
you assume that English is iid English
has context right so what people do is
they look at every word in some
constants let's say try one so you look
at each word and you look at the words
that preceded it like say two of them
and you try to estimate the probability
of the next word so that's how you're
going to decide what someone said they
look at the last two words and then you
have some estimate of of the next words
and you can you can factor that in so
each word is modeled in the context of
the previous towards okay so you're
looking in the probability for a die
conditioned on the previous two words so
now you need to estimate the
distribution of words not just once but
for every contest context of two words
okay so how many such context are
context are there there are 500,000
square so now the number of samples that
you need is 500,000 square times 800
million and that's two times ten to the
twenty or 220 approach there's a world
this number because otherwise I would
not remember so so that's so that's a
fairly large number already so you're
not excited now about you're not trying
to you know like address this this issue
so if you're not then let's look the
last thing after this I quit let's look
at the infinitive of it so we know that
many times main distribution you can
assume all of infinite alphabets right
let people look at Poisson distributions
and so on these distributions of
infinite alphabets and in that case the
number of samples if is infinity so if
you if you have a distribution over
infinitely many alphabets and you want
to estimate to given l1 distance then
let's say to not just point or one but
even to 0.5 and it infinitely many
samples okay so if you're not excited
here then maybe you are saying so so but
the point is here here is that maybe we
do not get so excited about something
going like K over square root of K over
N but maybe when we look at things
growing like at this rate we see that
it's actually important to to be able to
learn things faster and so so for all
these reasons so sample complexity is
the same as the approximation complexity
that we have talked about but we
sometimes call it the sensational
complexity so it's the same but I but
but it actually maybe points out the
importance of this estimation all right
so so the question that we have is maybe
is whether we are and and by the way I
think the goal was to have all slides be
like that but then phone and and laptop
and flight interfere so you know maybe
not all mm thanks so so so so so so so
looking at this you may be concerned
saying oh this is a very simple task and
already it requires so many so many
samples maybe it's useless right so
question is whether it's hopeless so
even the most basic problem just
estimating the distribution is requires
so many words okay how about more
complicated things that Google does like
you put a query to find things that are
related and so on or Amazon gives you a
combination we really care about
approximating the entire distribution
all I care about the popular words it's
not clear because when you do this it
means that you estimate some of the
popular words okay but typically words
are distributed say is if distribution
so they so they they have like heavy
tail so even though words many words
will have low probability but there's so
many of them they're together they
combine to something that does give you
but I mean it is true that this the fact
if even if you cannot learn a
distribution does not necessarily mean
that you cannot do other things but as
we will see later on actually these
things are very closely related but I
just want to say that you cannot say
that you ignore low probability words
because couple of reasons
like we said number one things are
distributed as if so so many of them
they actually occupy a lot of the
probability and number two some of these
things actually more like the most
popular words like a and they'd actually
meaningless so it's actually things that
are less likely that often carry more of
they so so so it seems like that even
the simplest problem is impossible okay
and yet Google solve this even more
complex form daily or even really
secondly and even kids can can solve
things right so obviously this this
concept of looking at the worst looking
at the worst possible approximation is
not doesn't capture something
so so what so question is what can we do
right to their kids and can do it what
can can we do and and that's what we now
group in other groups have spent like
the last 10 years I think trying to to
grapple with and and see what what can
we say beyond this this worst case that
we just described it okay so so I'm
going to talk about three approaches
okay one is are changing their
assumptions so so so far we said that
every distribution was possible okay
we've just said every distribution in
the simplex was possible but maybe we
can assume that the distribution has
some structure so maybe if we do that
then we see that we don't need a square
root of K over N maybe we can do better
so that's one assumption that's we're
going to do today tomorrow will Thursday
we'll talk about changing the problem so
instead of looking at trying to estimate
exactly exactly summation will try to
modify the problem a little bit and see
if that helps us reduce the number of
samples Thursday and then on Friday what
we'll do is we'll change the measure so
maybe instead of looking at the mean max
we're going to change the definition of
the measure of quality and see what can
be done and then we'll talk about
competitive approaches so these are the
three things that we're going to talk
about so so first adding structure okay
so so instead of assuming that we're
looking at all possible distribution in
the simplex that's that's a lot let's
assume that we have some subset s that
we can we can assume that the
distribution comes from so the estimator
is before we're observing and samples
and then we have an estimator in one up
to ek and and the estimation complex
your estimation accuracy for this set s
is defined to be just like before it's
the worst distance of e but now instead
of looking at the whole simplex we're
looking at some at some at some set
deston see for the worst distribution s
and the and the and the distance for
this this subset of distribution and n
is just the one that's achieved by the
best estimator distance for the worst
distribution s and this is the
estimation of era of learning s using n
samples so hopefully clear okay now for
us s does not stand for set it actually
stands for structure and and will you
can consider many different things you
can consider uniform distribution or
monotone distribution or low concave
distribution or the submissions that
maybe are a little more this may be too
too simplistic but you can think of mroe
F distribution goes up and down as most
n times smooth distributions or envelope
distribution so there are our and some
for some binomial many of those so there
are quintillion special cases apologize
I wrote this because I need to remember
what the word is
so the a lot of special cases and and
what I'm going to describe is a general
method that works for many of them so
rather than go into each so so again
what we're doing is we were saying if
you want to learn if you want make no
assumption no assumptions then we see
that you need a lot of samples in order
to learn distribution and we want to see
whether you can do it with fewer than
square root of K over N we're going to
make some assumptions so so we have some
class ok and we want to approximate it
so so if you have a function f on
server' distribution over k elements and
you have a function f that that's
defined on this elements k element then
we like PF bead the distribution that f
induces on the range of on its range so
for example if you have a distribution P
over 100 symbols and F is the parity
such a function then P F is going to be
the distribution of odd and over even
right on the probability that F is odd
and F is even and the probability of
Audis P one two three streams
PPF of even is just the sum of the human
poverty so is that clear so now we said
that the class okay so this P is what we
called s I apologize so a class P we
have various sums subclass P is M
epsilon M approximable if you can find a
function from 1 up to K - 1 up to M so
it's a contraction typically to a
smaller number such that if you have
taken it to distribution in your class P
ok then then the distance the actual
distance between them PQ the l1 distance
between them is that most the distance
the induced distance on the smaller on
the smaller range plus some Epsilon this
is this is your approximation this and
we'll call em like the in this case when
epson small we call m lu the effective
support size and epsilon is the error in
the approximation okay so so is that
clear so we have we if we have a
function f then the approximation error
is we're looking at the worst P and Q
and we're looking at the distance L 1
distance in the original domain we're
looking at the L 1 distance in this
contract contracted domain and then this
is the worst possible increase so how is
how is this approximation related to to
estimation to probability estimation so
we know that if you try to estimate in
this smaller domain in the M domain then
what we've seen is that you need at most
square root of M there's a constant
which I'm ignoring there is just most
you need at most square root of M over N
samples ok so this is in the small
domain so your smallest number is small
ok but if you now try to estimate in the
original domain 1 up to K then you can
see that the L 1 distance between P and
and it's approximation P hat if you take
appear to be any any any estimate that L
1 distance between P and P hat is at
most it's going to be at most the the
distance in the smaller domain
Plus this extra error that you pay
because of the because of this
contraction
so for nem we define this epsilon m to
be the largest this the largest
difference for any for any M epsilon M
is the largest this difference between
the original distance between P and Q
and they mapped distance between vehicle
this is the largest that the distance
could be so so our job is going to be to
show that you can do it with with small
Epsilon
so now if you have an if you have if you
try to estimate the distribution P then
what you'll do is you'll map it to the
smaller domain you'll estimate you'll
find an estimator in the smaller domain
okay and then you'll go back to the
original domain and you find P hat that
is consistent with you estimating the
smaller domain the P hat that will that
will map into into your estimate and
then what you know is that in the small
domain your difference is going to be at
most the square root of M over N and
because you're now mapping it back the
difference is that most is absolutely
never that you find so this gives you a
way to sound gives you a class you can
just plug this in and see how well you
can approximate it and and get the
result and that's what I was saying
before that I don't want to give you
people look at many different classes
and I don't want to give you like a
whole list of things and what people can
do I'm giving you one method and show
you how will show how it applies to two
to two courses so so the question is
someone gives you a class s question is
what is the best function that you can
do and then find the best effective
support and then you could get the
result so first let's look at envelope
distributions so what our envelope
distributions someone gives you alpha
which is bigger than one in a constant C
which is bigger than zero so the N fill
envelope Class C times I to the minus
alpha is the collection of P I letter at
most C times I to the minus alpha okay
so I'll give you essentially you can
think that I'm giving you
I'm giving you an upper bound on the
probability so tell you that P I is at
most five over I for example
[ __ ] I swear so I give you an upper
bound okay you not hear the case in this
case you don't see it but the alphabet
size here is actually infinity so if you
try to learn this like in the worst case
you need infinitely many samples why do
people care about envelope distributions
because if you like we said before lots
of times people said things behave like
distributions so it's like let's say one
over I of one over I Square and so on
but maybe you don't believe that it's
exactly one of Rye
but you believe it's at most 500 over I
yes so so so so this this is a reason to
to look at things I apologize for this
and so what we're going to show is that
you can absolute you can approximate you
cannot approximate the envelope class
with with epsilon if you reduce it to M
from infinity to M with epsilon which is
at most M to the alpha minus one so what
you can do is you can combine all this
small so if someone gives you a M you
combine all the elements from M onwards
you can combine them too you can combine
them together and keep the small
elements as they are so you contract it
to alphabet of size m and then if you
look at the summation of pi Y which is
bigger than M it's going to be you need
to sum you need to sum 1 over I to the
Alpha she's basically integrates you get
1 over m to the alpha minus 1 so you get
1 over integrate 1 over X to the Alpha
so you get from M onwards you get m to
the Alpha minus 1 so if you sum all the
elements from point onwards then then
this sum the tail this tail probability
is 1 we have like 1 over m to the alpha
minus 1 and what that means is that any
if you have any distribution can queue
in this whole original domain then the
distance between them is at most a
distance in the smaller domain plus
twice this quantity because it's most
that plus twice the tail because P could
be different there and Q could be
different there but you know that
there's some tight mostess value so it's
most twice that
so so what this shows you is that you
can compress this class envelope class
with at most square root of you can find
the best M but you get at most square
root of M over N plus this quantity so
all you need to do now is just equate
this to square root of M over N and this
quantity 1 over m to the alpha minus 1
and when you do that you'll see that I
find the best ms function of N and
you'll see that you get this this
quantity so it's at most 1 over N to the
Alpha minus wanded over 2 alpha minus 1
this is the rate at which you are you
can approximate so for example if this
is your class wave like 1 over I to the
1.5 then you can estimate it as 1 over N
to the quarter and that and notice that
this is now a distribution over over any
alphabet alphabet is infinite and this
result always hold so this is true even
though K is infinity so so so so it's
kind of a nice result because says if
you have if you have and if you assuming
distribution is the envelope
distribution then you can you you can
estimate the distribution with with a
loss that just depends on N and that's
it so I think the results is nice but it
doesn't really do what David said
earlier it's really just look at the
most popular words and those are the
ones that you classify correctly and you
kind of ignore the rest yeah so it does
and so you can see you may have
different issues with this and this
could be one of them ok noticed here
that we assume that alpha is bigger than
1 if alpha is bigger than 1 then
actually the tail probability goes down
yeah but yeah so I yeah so so that's why
we have 3 approaches if you don't like
this let's try the second one
no no yeah that's good yeah so yeah so
this it's true for this one it will not
be true for the next one so so but for
this this is the simplest example you
can do what David said you know see and
you know alpha and blue and so I think
that might you okay the the short answer
is no but to give credit to all the
people who are making in this you might
say you might look at empirically and
say that things you see how things
behave like because you've looked at
enough text documents and you know they
behave roughly like something and then
you maybe take some slack
the bigger issue here is that you assume
that you know the order that's the
bigger biggest issue like how do you
know the order of the words you might
know that the most likely word is
something the second most likely that's
the distribution but who tells you the
order that's a bigger issue here so what
is what is when we said that the
probability of in English the
probability for it is distributed zip
what does that mean
that means if means the behaves like 1
over I or 1 over I to some power okay
but what that means is that the most
likely word will be 1 over I won the
second one 1 over 2 to the our finest
third one third molars likely 1 over 3
to the alpha but it doesn't tell you
what the order is yet another
complication that adds to it so so this
so yeah so you get this I think these
are I think that I think so here's where
I'm coming to this I to me the palm of
estimating the submission is really
interesting because you know people have
looked at it for a long time and and
comes up in many applications to me this
is one of the basic problems in life you
observe data you want to know what is
done it like this you see if you can do
it well if you can do that well you can
do a lot of things so
at least you can you can write papers
can be you can get yeah you can get you
can get paid vacation so no the issue
the issue will come actually if you ask
me the issue is that maybe we need to
look at more complex distributions
because everything we're going to talk
about now is going to be iid but
ignoring that we review ideas the
building block so I think we need to
understand that but ignoring that I
actually strongly believe that it's a
really important question okay so given
that it's a real import question we need
to see what can you do so we started by
saying let's look at the basic
definition and we saw what you can do
exactly okay but the issue is that it's
- its - it's too pessimistic it's
looking at the worst distribution and
trying to see what do you get and this
is really too pessimistic square root of
K over N you might look nice but we saw
when we looked at the sample places
actually a lot okay so what we want to
say is what can you do and then we're
looking at different approaches that
people have taken to reduce that and
maybe in some applications may be
relevant some application maybe others
or relevant but I think it's important
to understand what each one gives you
what are the advantages and what are
their limitations so this is one in mind
you this is this is like the the
simplest example one his 2nd simplest
example one could come up with so so the
fact that you have some complaints and
so on is not surprising it's just an
example we can calculate using a simple
rule I want to show you a technique that
works so a bunch of things and clearly
to only work no but they're like there
were skeptical questions ok so so I
think I think I think we should
understand what what you can make what
assumptions you can make what they will
give you and so on that's that's the
process that we want so so what we're
doing today is we're saying let's assume
that you have you know today some
structure and like I said if you if you
go back if you if you go back to the
examples that I gave you I said that it
gets interesting in my mind not I said
the first time I said it gets
interesting is here this thing is
already interesting because you said
maybe people's heights you know unimodal
or something or maybe to model I think
this is where it gets interesting when
you look at uniform or monotone is not
so in my opinion
but at some point it will get practical
and of course the more complicated
things become the more samples you'll
need so that's one solution so maybe
this particular assumption was good for
for for you know for neck example that
maybe not in real life
but there will be if you get to this
then maybe becomes more interesting yeah
I didn't order them actually try to make
them kind of logical but so uniform and
then monotone and then monotone eConnect
log concave and then this kind of this
kind of extends this so I put it after
that you know and then smooth an
envelope a lost-time so okay so okay
yeah okay
and coffee break means that end of the
talk right okay so then let me select
right okay so let me just say monotone
distributions or what we think they are
okay and then what you can show is that
let me then just because this is
actually a longer proof so here you can
no longer do what David said from one of
the distribution you cannot just look
you know the last the last the final box
they actually need to look at everything
so so so for this you cannot beforehand
we had behaved like one over I to the
alfalfa bigger than one you could
because the tail went down but in this
case the tail does not necessarily go
down so so eventually what you can show
is I'm skipping but again you you map it
now it's a more complicated map II okay
but you can do it and when you do it
you'll get that you can approximate up
to this this valued log this value here
and if you look at M which is n to the
one third times log K then you'll get
that you you choose this M and you'll
get that you can approximate up to log K
over N to the one third so beforehand we
had square root of K over N now the K
went to locking so if the distribution
is monitor then it's not square root of
K over N that we need to worry about but
log key
yes just a very intuitively what you do
is your break you have an alphabet which
is 1 up to K and notice that for
monotone you cannot let K be infinity I
not noticeable is correct so now you
need to know K and what you do is you
break them into R into into bins that
increase exponentially so let's say size
is 1 2 4 and so on if you do that then
what you'll see is that essentially in
in some sense each block will have the
same the same could have the same
probability because the first one is
probably at most 1 the second one is
most half after went to 4 it's at most
one quarter so these blocks you can
think of them as having roughly in kind
of a bad sense the same probability in
it once you do it you estimate the
property of each of those blocks this is
your contraction and then you map it
back today to the sequence make it
uniform over each one when you do that
number of blocks is is log hey that's
what K became so this is log K over N to
the one to the one-third and I effect if
support size n to the one third times
located a so are there are many other
results so the most related results so
people have looked at mixtures of T
model distributions monotone hazard rate
distributions low concave distribution
was on binomial many results is just a
few of what people have looked at like I
said I'm trying to make you destroying
the parts and I'll give you everything
people have done just give you the idea
okay
and to get some of these things so in
this in this mapping our views the very
basic mapping but when you do the
mapping you can actually be a little
more precise in what you do so instead
of taking like a uniform distribution
you can make it distribution and so on
so so you get these results and then
besides these many results that people
have looked at so so the maybe one of
the first was burped in 87 he looked at
our monotone distributions his technique
was very similar to what what we
described now what we described is maybe
sort of amalgamation of looking at what
different people have done in looking at
the simplest version but if you look at
what he had done he has
this concepts are there of making the
blocks increasing the block y exponent X
peninsula so people looked in statistics
in information theory in computer
science and and and many many other but
we what we wanted is to give some
textbook examples maybe so not so
relevant about so and so just open end
up with an open forum all right now I
now I know what why the water got
spilled and I left my phone disappeared
okay so so we talked about learning in
terms of l1 distance but you can also
talk about learning in KL divergence and
then we have some law in upper bounds
but we don't have many cases we don't
have disability you described
corresponding to just the covering
number of the distribution class of
distributions is that what people
usually do under a shade constraints
there's a relation between the two I'm
not sure if there's a correspondent so
I'm not sure because here looking you
you're trying to have to approximate it
within an l1 distance and it's a little
different so I'm not sure not sure about
good question so typically the
distribution could have sort of a
product structure where you have a bunch
of features for example this class
that's right so one possibility one we
reduced another
tons of open forms and one of them that
we had in a previous version was to
include what happens in high dimensions
but I want to keep it so you don't shut
my computer I kept to one but yes
looking at what happens in in high
dimensions which has like this product
structure is another interesting